I had a story plan today but why why I
play team oh how cool oh one of the
things I think about legal edges a lot
of people think that it's not related
you know people scenes waste of time
playing games one of the things that I
found is increased self-awareness that I
really appreciate because one of the
things they have to do is within league
there are you know a couple hundred
champions that you could play and when
you first get into it you don't know who
to play and you don't know you know what
you're supposed to be doing and you need
to pick a champion that fits your
personality and so I found that I really
like strategic champions things where
you think more instead of having to be
mechanically skilled so there are some
people who like can move them their
fingers on their mouths their mouths
you know thousand miles an hour and can
get the exact combinations out super
quick that's not me I could do that if I
practiced enough but you know we play
once a day the people are playing eight
hours a day are the ones who can get
really skilled at that just like
anything else but strategy is something
that I'm naturally good at and so I
would have more success with the
champion that has a strategy component
to it or is highly you know strategy
oriented instead of the mechanical
skills and I started playing Teemo
because as you guys can see I guess when
you watch you kind of figure out what
we're doing it's a five versus five game
and you're trying to destroy the enemy
base and a lot of the map is dark you
don't know where anybody else is and one
of the biggest problems in the lower
tiers of the game is people don't create
vision so you can buy these things that
show you parts of the map and when you
have vision then allows you to see when
people are coming it allows you to make
escapes allows you to not get killed and
I was upset that nobody on my team was
getting vision and Timo has vision built
into his kit master unit victim master
yi so one of his abilities is to drop a
mushroom and the mushroom gives you
vision and so I started playing him
because I liked the ability to see what
was going on before I go and make the
move that's why I picked him and then
I'd learned to love him a lot more I'm
actually playing heimer in this game
again a champion of his way more
strategic than mechanics then I do well
my last timer I think it was okay right
I think it was been a wild game usually
I would do well a timer I feel like it's
been a while since I played him in the
last game I was a little rusty but I
think we think we won anyway so so I
typically do well with strategic things
and in helping people who've started
playing the game and they ask for what
champion should I play what's the best
champion right what's the best champion
going play who's the most powerful well
there is no one most powerful champion
just like there's no one most powerful
business to start the right answer is
the one that's right for you so what
kind of person are you because if you
play somebody who is not suitable to
your personality
you're not gonna have success so our
period above the self-awareness that
I've gained by um by playing the game
one minor adaptation I've made for most
of this stream I've been playing a carry
Teemo jungle style what that means is
the burden is on my shoulders to win the
game
well I'm taking a lot of horses I'm
pushing hard and if you look at my
scores or like 15 kills and 4 deaths or
something it's always always massively
in favor of me but then my teammates are
always dying right J and I do well on
the teams always feeding and we end up
losing especially recently we got a good
streak for a while and so yesterday I
tried a different style that actually
didn't work out but I'm not done with
the experiment of just being a more
supportive player of trying to do things
to get my team
had where if I see an opportunity to do
something myself
and take a you know take a kill or take
an objective than I will but my main
priority is getting up there and trying
to set up opportunities for my team to
be successful now it didn't really work
out all that great because we lost
yesterday and I had a bad score so I'm
not a bad score just not not my usual
like I'm gonna carry this I'm gonna
carry this this thing I think it's also
kind of reflective as of my growth as an
entrepreneur where at the start I was
doing everything myself and I will just
I will just carry this I will just do
everything and then relying more on the
team and saying hey how can I support
you and build you guys up and so I'm
trying to find the balance
so we'll see I was hoping to have a good
team Oh game here today and continue
that experiment and see what happened
but we're hai meraa mid and so if you
guys are watching here I placed these
turrets down and these things do most of
the attacking for me and so all that I
need to think about is where I put them
down so it's much more strategic and the
thing that you know I've worked with a
couple of League of Legends coaches and
people who are experts of the game and
built the that's the part that's missing
it's the same thing about teaching
people you know what what home business
should I start what's the hottest thing
for you know 2016 2017
nobody asked me well what kind of what
kind of person are you
yeah what do you like doing mmm right
that you say well this person is really
strong this is a great idea and it says
a lot of parallels it's a parallels for
everything mm-hmm doing things that suit
your personality and when you understand
your personality better and it was on me
to explain I want
I like strategy yes I can learn the
specifics I can learn the mechanics but
I'm naturally good at strategy and I
love it so give me something where I can
be more strategic and embrace the thing
that I'm good at and enjoy doing
anyway so that's my that's my story time
I love that I love that